Europium is an element which, when you excite
the atoms or excite the
electrons in the atoms, gives out very nice
red coloured light.
Ok, so europium is pretty much in the middle
of the lanthanide series.
Perhaps its most famous use is in television
screens.
In fact, most or many of the rare earths can
fluoresce in this way and
give out light, but europium is particularly
good at giving a very nice red
colour, and so europium salts are used in
television screens, not LCD
screens like you have on the laptop, but the
old-fashioned cathode ray
televisions.
So it’s very good at phosphorescence, for
example, so we use it in the
tubes in TV screens to get different colours.
The screen on the inside of the screen you
have dots of europium and
when the electrons from the electron beam
in the cathode ray tube hit
the europium you get a very intense emission
of red light which gives
you the red colour to form the colour television
pictures.